bien mes chers qu'eux nous allons
reprendre nos travaux en auditionnant ce
matin monsieur xavier niel fondateur et
actionnaire du groupe iliad je rappelle
que cette commission d' enquête a été
demandée par le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
et à pourra porter david assouline
notionnels la commission vous remercier
d'avoir pu vous rendre disponible pour
venir apporter votre témoignage échanger
avec vous
sur la problématique de la commission à
savoir la concentration des médias avec
free vous avez été le pionnier en france
de l'offre dite de triple-play rendue
possible par les box internet
aujourd'hui présent dans l'écran
l'écrasante majorité des foyers vous
avez commencé à investir dans la presse
en 2010 avec la prise de contrôle du
groupe le monde en compagnie de matthieu
pigasse que nous avons auditionné à
quelques jours et de pierre bergé au
décès de ce dernier matthieu pigasse a
cédé 49 % de ses parts à daniel de
chritine ce qui avoue 3 vous dépeignez
donc 72% un peu plus de 72% du groupe
cependant le mercredi 26 janvier il a
par ailleurs été annoncé que vous aviez
acquis le solde des parts de matthieu
pigasse que nous avons entendu comme je
le disais le 28 janvier en avril dernier
vous avez transféré dans une fondation
pour un euro symbolique l'intégralité de
vos participations dans la presse soit
le monde l'ops nice-matin et france
antilles ainsi que paris turf enfin vous
avez manifesté
votre intérêt pour le rachat des parts
de bernard tapie dans le groupe la
provence dont vous êtes déjà actionnaire
à hauteur de 11% si je ne me trompe pas
vous retrouver en concurrence avec
rodolphe saadé président de la compagnie
maritime cm à cgm qui a communiqué le 15
février sur une offre de 80 1 millions
d'euros pourrait peut-être enfin vous
serez sûr tellement interrogé sur ce
point m e pourrait peut être en parler
dans votre propos liminaire
monsieur niel vous incarnez comme
d'autres ces grands industriels qui
choisissent d'investir dans le secteur
qui leur est a priori étrangers en tout
cas au débat au départ de l' aventure
industrielle les médias ce qui suscite
bien sûr des interrogations légitimes de
nos concitoyens et de la commission
sommes donc heureux de pouvoir vous
entendre sur les origines de cet
engagement ainsi que sur votre vision de
l'indépendance des rédactions à ce titre
je signale que le monde opère dorénavant
souvent une structure complexe qu elles
ont besoin d'avoir aussi vos
éclairages qui est supposé suture
complexe qui est supposé en garantir
l'indépendance je vous propose
l'organisation suivante pour notre
commission de ce matin je vais vous
laisser la parole comme on le fait à
chaque fois pour un propos liminaire de
dix minutes et ensuite nous vous
poserons des questions réponses ce sera
enfin nous nous posons des questions
vous y apporterait des réponses non pas
en me tournant vers des david assouline
je parle de questions réponses mais non
c'est bien il formera des questions ils
vous font vibrer les réponses et
bien sûr
nous prendrons le temps d'échanger pour
que cette audition soit enrichissante je
précise que cette audition est diffusée
en direct sur le site internet du scénar
et fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu qui sera publié enfin je rappelle
pour la forme qu un faux témoignage
devant notre commission denquête
seraient passibles des peines prévues
aux articles 4 134 tirs et 13 14 et 15
du code pénal je vous précise également
qu'il vous appartient le cas échéant
d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts au conflit d'intérêts en
relation avec l'objet de la commission
denquête je vais vous invitez maintenant
monsieur nyala a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure je vous remercie et donc je vous
donne la parole pour dix minutes
le bouton mais c'est fait c'est
automatique monsieur le rapporteur on
m'a dit alors que c'était devenu
automatique très très bien je m'en
excuse non je j'ai aujourd'hui quatre
quatre grandes activités qui vivent
chacun dans une dans une indépendance et
qui ont chacun d'entre elles une
croissance
une croissance la première c'est celle
que vous avez cités c'est celle des
télécommunications
est-ce que c'est mieux pardon donc donc
je pense que comme je vous le disais
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quatre activités
principales c'est une activité
d'actionnaires parfois de de gestion
dans le cadre des télécoms de ses
activités la première c'est celle où il
avait cité des télécommunications j'ai
créé mon premier opérateur de
télécommunications il ya 35 ans
maintenant j'avais tout juste 18 ans je
suis originaire d'une ville qui
s'appelle créteil en banlieue
parisienne celui d'origine d'une famille
royale française mode je sais pas comme
on dit et en fait j'ai
j'ai été j'ai fait partie j'ai eu la
chance de faire partie des premiers à
s'intéresser en fait à la à la
numérisation des choses de la
numérisation et la mise en ligne des
choses c'était à ces moments là c'est
peu répandue en france et j'ai développé
cette activité aujourd'hui cette
activité a grossi avec de nombreux
partenariats et je jouerai contrôler une
petite une petite vingtaine d'opérateurs
de télécommunications dans le dans le
monde dans différents pays et puis
toujours avec une volonté d'expansion il
ya quelques mois on a racheté à a le
plus gros taper le plus grand opérateur
de pologne ou des choses comme ça il
faut qu'on continue à se développer sur
tous ces territoires et pourquoi on le
fait parce que le marché français est un
marché
dans lequel on croit tout réussir à
gagner significativement de parts de
marché difficiles et donc on va au delà
de nos frontières plutôt en europe mais
on se développe aussi aux états unis et
ailleurs et on continue de grossir dans
ses activités c'est ma première activité
historique j'ai eu une deuxième activité
qui est l'immobilier
en fait pendant longtemps le sujet des
nouvelles
technologies par et c'est un secteur
qu'ils pouvaient avoir ou avoir des
problèmes et donc l'argent que j'ai pu
gagner des télécommunications tout au
début a été réinvesti dans l'immobilier
et est à ce titre avec le temps on a
créé plusieurs foncières on a financé
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs danser dans ces
secteurs et on s'est développé jusqu'à
arriver au début du confinement à
prendre une participation d'un peu plus
de 20% dans le groupe
unibail et univers hors d'un coup est
field et est de continuer à développer
cette activité ont vachement
régulièrement des actifs et là encore
une fois on est dans un marché français
qui est significatif grand même un
marché parisien qui est significatif
grand donc on a énormément de travail ou
de potentiel de développement et on
continue de le faire dans cette zone
mais au-delà de ça on commence à sortir
de ses frontières une troisième activité
encore une fois qui est complètement
indépendante 1 se sont se sont pas des
groupes de sociétés qui appartiennent à
une holding ce sont vraiment des
activités indépendantes avec des
dirigeants différent d actionnariat et d
actionnariat minoritaire généralement
différents et donc dans cette troisième
activité l'idée c'était de dire
j'ai eu la chance au travers de
l'entrepreneuriat à l'âge de 18 ans ou
17 18 19 ans de réussir au moins
financièrement ma vie et à partir de ce
moment là est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas
cohérents ou essayer de se dire que
qu'est-ce que je peux faire comment je
peux avancer pour essayer de d'aider
d'autres avoir cette même chance et de
pousser d'autres personnes à
l'entrepreneuriat est donc dans le camp
de ce cadre là j'ai commencé à financer
des start-up ya très longtemps réel
travail et 25 30 ans et sur la base de
ce financement de start-up ensuite on
s'est dit ok mais il faut aider notre
écosystème français hélas est l inverse
parce qu'on a commencé à l'international
d'écosystèmes les français tartas
française était faible et aujourd'hui on
est principalement dans un financement
de start-up française pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur on finance entre
100 et 150 start up chaque année en
france dans tous les secteurs et donc
sur la base de ça on s'est dit comment
on peut continuer d'aider cet écosystème
ça a été notamment l'idée de la création
de l'école carnot 2 c'est une école
gratuite qui est à paris qui a 4000
élèves et je crois que maintenant on a
40 40 un peu moins tu es un peu plus que
40 entre 40 et 45 écoles dont j'espère
que cette année on en ouvrira quelques
dizaines toujours sur le même modèle
d'une école gratuite
verte à tous dans lequel on pose pas de
questions sur le passé ou les passifs de
nos de nos étudiants et puis on leur
apprend un métier et quand il sort de
cette école si vous sortez de cette
école à paris vous avez une rémunération
aujourd'hui entre 40 et 50 ans si vous
avez décroché de l'école à 14 ans on
vous apprend ça vous apprend ce métier
des nouvelles technologies à coder
d'affaires du code informatique et après
vous avez une demande ou ploie
incroyable je sais pas peut-être 30
demandes de stage par élève qui sont
dans ces écoles est donc une garantie
certaine d'un emploi bien rémunéré et
est donc là dessus sur la base de cette
idée là toujours pour aider
l'entrepreneur on a lancé une autre
initiative pareille qui n'a pas destiné
à être rentable qui s'appelle station
être les plus grands incubateur du monde
qui est à paris est toujours avec
exactement cette même idée comment on
pousse des jeunes l ordre comprenant est
recommandé de l'entrepreneuriat c'est un
lieu dans lequel on accueille
physiquement un millier de start up
chaque année ça tourne chaque année et
le lieu se développe on continue
d'essayer de développer autour on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait un problème de
logement dont on a rajouté un immeuble
dans lequel des immeubles autour on a on
a 600 logements et donc on est autour de
ce thème et puis une troisième activité
qui est celle qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui qui sont la presse et d'une
manière plus générale la communication
audiovisuelle dans cette activité là
excusez moi de venir pour monsieur le
président j'ai créé mon premier journal
à l'âge de 20 ans j'attends que je vous
remercie parce que c'était paillard et
entendent malheureusement j'aurais bien
aimé mais c'était il ya un petit peu
plus longtemps
et depuis cette date là j'ai toujours
été éditeur de journaux et j'ai financé
un grand nombre d'initiatives qui sont
qui ont existé
dans celle que parfois on ne peut me
reprocher ou vous dire que ça peut être
des sujets mais ce sont des journaux
politiquement qui vont de l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite tous et encore
une fois mon avis politique ne compte
pas ce que je souhaite c'est que ces
journaux soient indépendants parce que
s'ils sont indépendants ils vont exister
et ont développé et sur la base de
ces idées-là de ces financements là qui
pouvaient exister d'elle en ce sens les
contrôles et je pense à partir des
années 2000 est arrivé l'histoire du
monde que matthieu pigasse avait vu
comme étant dans la difficulté avec un
risque potentiel d'une prise de contrôle
complexe potentiellement soufflé par
l'état et mathieu est venu voir en me
disant faut qu'on fasse quelque chose on
allait voir pierre bergé qui nous est
dit je fais ça avec vous et donc à ce
moment là nous avons pris contrôle du
monde qui était dans la dans la
difficulté juste pour vous donner
quelques chiffres et puis après j'ai
continué dans un certain nombre de
médias locaux des cités juste pour vous
donner quelques chiffres parce que
qu'est ce que l'on fait au monde et je
suis sûr qu'on me poserais des questions
ensuite le monde quand on est arrivés
vendait moins de trois cent mille
exemplaires aujourd'hui vingt cinq cent
mille exemplaires donc en dix ans en
douze ans on a ramené le monde en termes
de ventes en termes de diffusion à des
niveaux jamais atteints dans toute son
histoire
en 2010 le monde comptait 300
journalistes aujourd'hui la 500
journalistes c'était quoi l'idée le
constate le concept c'est de dire si
vous achetez un média si vous achetez un
journal surtout un journal si vous
achetez un journal et que vous voyez les
difficultés et que vous virer les
journalistes vous allez - vent et si
vous vendez - la balance vous aller
virer plus de journalistes vous allez
moindre et à la fin votre média
disparaît est en fait le pari que l'on a
faits au début avec mathieu et pierre
consistait à dire faisons inverse
augmentons le la rédaction les budgets
alloués aux rédactions et à partir de ce
moment-là le journal va se rendre va
fonctionner créons leur tout un tout
c'est tout un système qui va leur
garantir leur possibilité d'écrire sur
que ce qu'ils veulent et ils soyons
justes ceux qui vont s'occuper
d'économie en fait c'est par où le mode
de fonctionnement confiez-nous la
gestion économique et vous prenez la
gestion éditoriale et ce partenariat qui
a été fait avec un une entité qui
s'appelle le pôle d'indépendance et je
suis sûr qu'on en reparlera a plutôt
bien fonctionné puisque à l'époque quand
nous sommes arrivés en 2010 le groupe le
monde perdait 32 millions d'euros je
crois que l'année dernière il a fait 22
millions de en 2021 de 22 millions
d'euros d'ebitda donc on a changé
complètement la donne il ya un dernier
sujet donc n'avait pas parlé mais de la
même manière avec matthieu pigasse et
puis pierre en train de cape town un
brillant producteur donc sam associés
pour créer une société
média one et avec 1 1 un concept assez
simple c'est tout repose sur la
créativité et le moteur de la réussite
économique d'une société de production
repose sur la créativité et à côté de ça
ça te permet d'avoir un impact sur le
rayonnement de la france si on est
capable de créer des producteurs cette
créativité à vient du cerveau des hommes
et donc qu'est ce que l'on a essayé de
faire on va essayer d'agréger un grand
nombre de producteurs ont appris ces
producteurs ont les agrégés dans une
dans une entité des producteurs
indépendants qui en général était petit
avec les mauvaises conditions de
distribution dont les a aidés on les a
aidés à porter des projets dans la durée
ou les a aidé à financer ses projets
dans l'est dans la durée de les aider à
écrire des droits d'adaptation pour
peser face aux gros acheteurs du marché
parce que évidemment quand vous êtes un
petit producteur et vous allez voir
tf1 ou neflix c'est pas pour les mêmes
contenus mais votre capacité dont il
sait que vous êtes dépendant de et donc
à partir de ce moment là votre capacité
de négociation est là et qu'est-ce que
devenu mais yoann média one est devenu
un des trois leaders européens la
production en marche incroyablement bien
en france on est en train de produire
des leaders européens et des leaders
mondiaux bien que notre part de marché
reste incroyablement modestes même si on
a acquis en europe 70 environ 70
sociétés la part de marché de média one
reste modérée je crois que des personnes
que vous avez entendu vous ai dit qu'à
4000 producteurs quelques petits
producteurs en france désolé j'étais
trop long mais je vous écoute pour vos
questions
il met fin à la première question de
david assouline autres rapporteurs
dont vous n'avez pas fait l'eau puisque
vous n'avez pas utilisé tout le temps
qu'on vous donner
merci d'être là monsieur niaid
vous faites partie de ces grands
propriétaires on va dire de médias que
kiss ou
très attendu dans ces auditions parce
que le coeur même de notre de notre
objet qui est la concentration des
médias
touche
touche de façon importante
vos activités puisque
vous êtes parmi ceux qui
[Musique]
concentrent de façon verticale et c'est
une des nouveautés que nous étudions
puisque dans la loi de 86 qui
réfléchissait à comment réguler le monde
médiatique
la téléphonie ne pouvait pas dans leur
champ de vision à l'époque même pour les
plus
prophète et donc
c'est un c'est un vrai sujet de
réflexion pour nous vous êtes dans la
presse écrite vous êtes
donc dans la téléphonie et dans la
production de programmes avec
médiane
j'ai envie de vous poser une question de
journaliste puisque c'est une question
de journaliste réel très grande
journaliste d'ailleurs qui travaille au
monde et qui
s'interrogeait selon des propos
rapportés par mediapart sur vos
motivations au moment de la création du
fonds dont on a parlé vous avez parlé
elle aurait dit de la part de xavier
niel est ce une affaire d'image ou une
affaire de conviction
alors de façon un peu sèche pour
commencer pourriez vous répondre à
l'interrogation de cette excellente
journaliste
pour les mineurs ils sont très gentils
zap mama place ils sont très très bien
les équipes du sénat merci à elle mais
elle pardon mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que vous parlez concentration des
médias mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
de regarder la concentration de la
diffusion de cette information c'est à
dire un article du monde un article du
monde normal c'est cent mille lecteurs
le journal de tf1 à 20 heures tous les
soirs ces cinq à six millions de
personnes donc il ya un rapport de 1 à
1,50 à 1,60 donc la concentration des
médias et notamment des médias presque
bascule d'un digital le leur lors leur
influence ou leur poids est
incroyablement
délayé par rapport à d'autres médias et
donc je pense qu'il est incroyablement
important quand vous évoquez le les
sujets de quotas ou des éléments qui
peuvent exister de commencer à mesurer
la réalité delà de la puissance de ces
médias mais c'était un propos liminaire
sur la question qui est je crois c'est
raphaël paquet qui est là la dirige la
personne qui qui s'occupe du pôle
d'indépendance
du monde je vous le dis pour moi c'est
une activité industrielle j'ai gagné
j'ai gagné de l'argent dans la presse
j'ai eu le plaisir d'être associée avec
la lembeye qui est un entrepreneur des
médias incroyablement génial j'étais
associé avec lui j'étais associé dans
ses holdings a écrit un jour de l'été si
des dents du 07 actifs à un concurrent
vous avez un concurrent patrick drahi
qui a payé un prix incroyable et on a
vendu donc si vous voulez si j'étais
dans une dans un dans un souhait de
contrôle de médias pour avoir pouvoir d'
influence quelconque je regardais bfm
télé et ce n'est pas ce que j'ai fait
avec un la veille ont été rappelés donc
vous vous dites en fait c'est la
question image ou affaire de conviction
vous dit ni l'un ni l'autre c'est une
affaire de business je crois plusieurs
choses hein je crois qu'on a besoin
d'une liberté de la presse et de liberté
de la presse n'existe pas toujours en
france il ya un certain nombre de médias
où je trouve que parfois et gégé et
parfois je les subis parce que je peux
me retrouver dans des sujets de
concurrence on a un certain nombre de
médias qui ont une ligne éditoriale qui
tend qui a tendance servir les intérêts
économiques ou financiers de leurs
actionnaires c'est un choix c'est leur
choix à côté de ça c'est pas ma vision
des médias ma vision des médias c'est
qu'on doit avoir des médias pour tout le
monde et qui sont capables de diffuser
cette information
avec matthieu pigasse on est contrôlé en
contrôlant veut pas ça veut dire mais
contrôlant du monde diplomatique la
ligne du monde diplomatique n'est
probablement peut-être pas ma ligne mais
qu'ils continuent de faire leur job qui
continue même d'agresser leurs
actionnaires c'est très bien je veux
dire ils font leur job ils ont leur
ligne éditoriale c'est un journal que
vous pouvez qualifier d'opinion je suis
confortable avec ça et puis de l'autre
côté vous avez
le
jet pack suez actionnaire de causeur qui
je pense peut représenter une ligne un
peu différent tout datant clicquot qui
peut représenter une différente encore
une fois c'est je ne pense que c'est
potentiellement pas ma ligne
d'esprit où mon idée mais je souhaite la
plus grande liberté au bout de ça une
fois qu'on a dit ça voyant que ces
médias peuvent attirer des gens qui
peuvent avoir des envies pas saine
plutôt que de se dire à un moment de
souhaiter les remettre sur le marché de
les revendre je me suis dit essayons les
protégés de manière plus durable
empêchant qu'ils deviennent ses cibles
laissons les les gens qui les font parce
que les gens qui créent cette valeur
qu'ils créent la valeur de ces médias ce
sont les journalistes au bout et des
allons avec eux travaillons avec eux et
aidons les à assurer leur indépendance
leur capacité de travail et d'écrire de
faire ce qu'il souhaite mais on est tous
le départ est donc le fonds de dotation
c'est justement cette idée et encore une
fois je suis un industriel
à bien gagner sa vie dans chacune de ses
activités mais qui un instant de raisons
se dit créant un fonds pour protéger le
contrôle de ses
comédiens j'ai une rencontre à sion
verticale dans chacune de mes activités
j'ai une concentration verticale mais je
n'ai aucune synergie entre mes activités
les dirigeants du monde ne connaissent
pas les dirigeants de free c'est des
mondes complètement séparée qui ne se
dit pas ils ont un de leurs actionnaires
dans les deux cas qui écope
donc ça ça explique une question que je
voulais vous poser parce qu'en
on s'interroge
dans que de la logique poursuivie si
vous préférez quand il ya
des titres aussi divers que le monde
paris turf ou ou france antilles bon
j'avais envie de vous poser cc c'est
quoi le fil conducteur du projet
d'ailleurs certains vous ont reproché
parfois de ne jamais avoir annoncé votre
stratégie de long terme par rapport à
la presse qui n'est pas une activité
comme les autres en terme de deux
business on va dire c'est doux touche à
quelque chose d'important
l'information pour les citoyens au
fonctionnement de la démocratie
vous nous dites en gros pour moi c'est
un business à côté des autres business
et donc quand il ya une opportunité je
prends et c'est pour ça qu'il ya pas de
cohérence en fait entre le monde paris
turf ou france antilles
mais vous pouvez me corriger le nom je
vous en prie j'essaie de résumer ce que
je comprend enfin la même bannière
pourriez me dire n'y a pas de fil
conducteur entre
le fait d'exploiter free en france et
d'exploiter un opérateur en irlande où
un opérateur aux mains de paul à monaco
donc si vous voulez le fil conducteur
c'est une activité pour moi et cette
activité historiquement quand je suis
parti dans cette activité et c'était une
activité industrielle encore une fois
j'ai gagné de l'argent dans la presse à
l'âge de 20 ans donc c'est une activité
pour moi industriels à un moment j'ai
dix ans me rends me rendant compte que
cette activité pouvait attirer des gens
qui avaient potentiellement d'autres
idées derrière la tête potentiellement
encore une fois c'est pas à moi de juger
ou de préjugés je me suis dit que
peut-être mon niveau de l'argent que
j'avais gagné en france allez pouvoir me
permettre de créer de grandes ses
activités - mercante non mercantile pour
moi non mercantile par mois ne pas en
tirer un avantage fiscal en les amenant
on les donne en les cédant pardon pour
un euro à une fondation
peut-être la prise de conscience que
c'est un bien commun un peu comme vous
le dites une prise de conscience que
c'est un bien commun et que ce bien
commun il ya des gens qui ont envie de
se l'approprier et donc c'est exactement
inverse deux ce que je pense j'ai pu
avoir peut-être penser autre chose il ya
20 ans mais c'est exactement inverse de
ce que je peux penser aujourd'hui il se
dire bon essayons préserver la totalité
de ses actifs et pour vous reprendre
monsieur le président c'est créer un
fonds de dotation de nam dinh que des
titres rentables c'est à dire de ne pas
amener des titres non rentables amener
des titres non rentables un fonds de
dotation c'est un moyen de s'en
débarrasser donc c'est tout l'inversé on
amène le monde a selon dotation une
participation du monde dans ce fonds de
dotation la totalité de ma participation
dans le fonds de dotation parce que on
va être rentable parce que la société
rentable durablement parce que le monde
voulait dit à faire plus de 20 millions
de résultat l'année dernière parce que
le monde a réussi à acheter son immeuble
ce qui est dans le monde de la presse on
parle du monde réussie à s'acheter un
immeuble de 170 millions d'euros il
appartient au monde cet immeuble est
donc à partir de ce moment là je pense
qu'on a un groupe qui est capable de
vivre de manière indépendante ça veut
pas dire al'inverse qui peut de nouveau
être gérée par les journalistes ça peut
pas dire à linverse que la partie
éditoriale peut être géré par le fonds
de dotation il faut que ces choses
soient faites de manière séparée parce
que c'est ce qui a démontré et c'est ce
qui a fait que ça marche nice matin qui
a été rentable 3d au cours des trois
quatre derniers ou trois quatre derniers
mois de la même manière quand il sera
redirigé durablement aux fonctions dans
la manière durable et bien l'idée c'est
de l'année de nouveau à ce fonds de la
norme est d'amener que des médias on
tape même chose pour paris turf et les
autres jeux
des précisions
sur ce fonds
dont les statuts de ce fonds montre que
vous conservez une part importante dans
sa conduite en particulier vous nommer
quatre administrateurs sur six dont deux
après consultation du pôle
d'indépendance et vous pouvez les
révoquer à tout moment
pourquoi vous n'avez pas été jusqu'au
bout de la démarche qu'ils sont maîtres
affiché qui est affichée en affirmant
très clairement une indépendance plus
absolu des titres par rapport aux
fondateurs que vous êtes alors il ya
plusieurs raisons déjà on y va par étape
c'est à dire que je suis en plein
contrôle et en totalité des droits dans
la société qui co détient le d'accord
c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est le nous le
nouveau monde lml temps dans le monde et
je m'en excuse on a beaucoup de monde
dans le dans les dents là je crois que
vous avez un organigramme
comme le montage est un peu compliquée
est ce qu'on peut projeter en même temps
ce qui nous permettra de mieux décrypter
et donc les cetc source le monde parce
que nous ait fait une projection et j'ai
eu des contestations sur les sourds
c'est sur ce monde je contesterai ce
schéma bien une partie contestable
puisque nous n'avons pas encore matthieu
pigasse a faim les entités que contrôle
matthieu pigasse et et les entités et
que je contrôle parce qu'ils n'ont elles
ne sont pas encore physiquement a mené
au fond il offre une dotation qui hélas
sont encore puisque à une contestation
de l'ayant droit de pierre bergé ne sont
pas encore de propriété alors que là ils
sont vus comme d'autres propriétés mais
enfin une décision de justice qui vous
donne raison donc on peut supposer qu'il
est que ces actions devraient être
mais bon c'est l'esprit et c'est vers ce
vers quoi on se dirige dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent sur le sur ce
fonds ok il y à aujourd'hui si man 2 que
j'ai nommé directement qui sont
roxanne varza qui dirige station elf et
qui est destinée qui connaît le digital
et je pense que c'est une expérience
importante pour le digital et mon fils
alors je suis pas du tout dans le
népotisme je suis pas emballé par
l'héritage outre mesure je pense qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous ont déjà vu
pour essayer de défendre des mesures
permettant de les lire déshérités nous
permettent de mon vivant de faire ce que
je souhaitais de ma fortune dans le
cadre des choses dans l'intérêt
collectif je n'ai pas encore réussi à me
faire entendre sur le sujet mais je suis
sûr qu'on y arrivera c'est pas trop mon
truc mais pourquoi mon fils se retrouve
dans ce sujet simplement à la demande du
journal à la demande du pôle
d'indépendance et le pôle d'indépendance
a dit attends si un jour on a un
problème qui sera plus là je sais c'est
dur parfois d'être aimé si un jour on a
un problème financier tu seras plus là
qu'est ce qu'on fera bas mais quelqu'un
on veut sûr on veut une turquie soit là
on veut exclure que soit la voilà donc
je dit écoutez si je vous mets mon fils
je vais pas vous portez vous êtes sur
wii donc ce sont les deux mots que j'ai
choisi à côté de ça il y a deux autres
membres qui sont collectivement
conjointement choisi le pôle
d'indépendance et moi même alors le pôle
d'indépendance et moi même donc ce choix
aujourd'hui ses effets sur deux
personnes alain frachon ancien directeur
de rédaction du monde on va supposer que
le choix qu'on a fait collectivement est
un choix assez sain mais encore une fois
on peut se tromper qui sera le président
chez le président pardon de ce fonds et
nicole notât
encore une fois c'est leur choix moi je
ne connais pas ni de colmatage et n'a
jamais elle était au conseil de
surveillance du monde ya très longtemps
je n'ai jamais déjeuné avec nicole notât
je ne la connais pas je n'ai pas son
numéro de téléphone mobile
c'est un choix on fait un choix en
commun moi ça va très bien et puis deux
autres
personnes sont là notamment un
journaliste de télérama qui est présent
la choisis par le pôle d'indépendance et
une
dernière personne qui est choisi par
matthieu pigasse et qui est à sa main
donc si vous voulez le fonctionnement
évidemment on peut le résumer en disant
il a la possibilité de révoquer
n'importe qui mais le jour où je vais
révoquer une seule personne une seule
personne dans ce fonds je vais tout le
monde a crié au scandale et tout ce que
je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui ne
sera plus crédible ça n'existe pas ce
sujet n'existe pas mais je pense qu'il
ya comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
quelque chose d'incroyablement important
c'est de continuer d'amener ce
savoir-faire de gestion et avoir envie
d'accompagner ce savoir-faire de gestion
qui est important qui fait que le groupe
le monde est rentable et cette
rentabilité dans un titre de presse
sacré l'indépendance et de l'autre côté
de données toujours plus d'indépendance
aux journalistes à dire que chaque fois
à tous les étages du monde il y a des
règles de protection de l'indépendance
éditoriale et ça se dit devant vous mais
ça se prouve l'indépendance éditoriale
et si vous vous posez une question tout
à l'heure et bien j'aurai le plaisir le
pour parler de ce sujet je voudrais
revenir un peu sur ce fond bien sûr
l'indépendance sur ce fond pour
l'indépendance de la presse parce que
certains disent que le modèle des fonds
sont un des modèles vertueux pour
notamment assurer
une pluralité de dans
la propriété des journaux vos statuts
quand même disent pas la même chose
c'est pour ça que me permet des rebelles
sur l'arctique 5,1 dont vous nous avez
parlé concernant les administrateurs
effectivement ils sont au nombre de 6 2
sont nommés par le fondateur vous et
deux autres par le fondateur après
consultation du pôle d'indépendance
c'est la vie nicole notât dont vous avez
par le pôle de la dépense est un
paramètre que pigasse donc sur les six
indirectement il y en a quatre qui
dépendent de votre nomination nick vous
nous avez dit nicole notât et alain
frachon n'avait pas été nommé par vous
offre pour autant le médiapart je crois
dans un article il ya quelques mois ils
disaient qu'ils avaient été proposées
par vous même vous dire et je continue
200 questions sur le front de l'est
je les pose dans la continuité sur
l'article 5 7 il est prévu que le
président du conseil d'administration du
fonds est désigné par le fondateur c'est
à dire vous même parmi les membres du
conseil d'administration et le fondateur
pourra décider à tout moment de désigner
un autre membre du conseil du mode
d'administration en qualité de président
donc à la fois un pouvoir de nomination
et de révocation du président et enfin
dans un article 14 est prévu qu'en cas
de décès du fondateur les droits du
fondateur au titre des présents statuts
se transmettront de plein droit à ses
ayants droit je ne conteste pas du tout
la
légitimité de ces articles mais quand
même ça traduit que c'est vous qui avez
la maîtrise du fonds et
on n'est pas sur un fond qui traduit
l'indépendance par rapport à par rapport
à des propriétaires vous en avez
entièrement la maîtrise je suis je lui
on va reprendre point par point d'accord
le sur les nominations vous pouvez jeu
sur vous pouvez interroger pôle
d'indépendance la manière dont ça s'est
passé ils ont choisi demain on a discuté
ils ont choisi de membres et c'est
fantastique ça sur les nominations donc
ça c'est le cas concret mais les statuts
il ya la réalité premier élément le
deuxième élément sur la révocation c'est
probablement exacte ce qui s'est écrit
ça doit être exact maintenant le jour où
vous allez révoquer un membre de ce fond
vous allez vous tapez un scandale
incroyable je veux dire je vous allez
vous à les décrédibiliser le journal
vous allez décrire vidil décrédibiliser
votre actif je dirais se retrouverait
alors pourquoi l'écrire dans les statuts
sais pas ce que vous faites les choses
progressivement on y va doucement j'ai
un actif d'accord j'ai un actif tiens
une valeur visiblement significative
cette valeur significative le don qui
est fait à ce fonds c'est à dire que ces
pertes de valeur pour moi elle est
importante significative donc vous
faites le chemin tout doucement je sais
que le monde parfait vous si votre monde
parfait c'est de dire on prend tous les
médias ont créé une grande fondation
française on met tous les médias là
dedans c'est une idée moi je suis pour
mais je pense que de tous les gens vous
avez entendu ici je vais être le seul
qui va être pour donc si vous voulez on
y va doucement ont fait le boulot et on
avance et encore une fois c'est pas ça
l'idée de ce fonds c'est quoi c'est pas
de protéger l'indépendance du monde
c'est protéger le capital du monde
depuis le début c'est de protéger le
capital humain parce que vous lisez les
statuts qu'est ce qu'il est dit dans ses
statuts il est impossible de céder le
capital de cette société sans un nombre
d'accords incroyable que vous les
statuts sous les yeux probablement vous
ne trouvez il est impossible de selliers
capital de cette société mais c'est ça
c'est ça qu'on a cherché à préserver
donc mme chénel c'est de notre sujet
n'est pas de dire
si c'est bien ou mal le fond et et moi
j'ai mon idée d'autres peuvent avoir
leurs idées je pense que c'est une
originalité qui est salué par rapport à
d'autres mais c'est le question c'est
pour aller au fond parce que ce que vous
affichez
pour garantir l'indépendance de ce média
des autres médias comme comme comme ils
ont
objectifs et conviction profonde et
comme est quand même plus limitée que ce
qui est affiché parce que effectivement
vous gardez une fine et le contrôleur on
peut dire vous n'en abusez pas c'est ce
que vous nous dites en gros en gros la
révocation si je faisais ça ce serait
terrible on connaît notre patron de
presse qui
n'hésiteraient pas et considère que
c'est par la révocation qu'il redore le
blason rouleur médias ou alors même qui
révoque et ensuite leur média cool et
c'est pas trop important pour eux parce
que ce qui est important c'est leur
pouvoir il ya beaucoup de cas et nous on
regarde pas les individus ou quand on
parle d'une structure on regarde
qu'est ce qu'elle permet qu est ce qu
elle ne permet pas donc vous avez fait
ce fonds il affiche d'abord la volonté
d'indépendance
capitalistiques notamment vous le
protégé de cette façon s'est montrée en
exemple moi ça m'intéresse en tous les
cas comme montage parce que on réfléchit
tout ce qu'est ce qui permettrait dans
ce climat de concentration au moins
d'assurer que les journalistes et les
titres puissent avoir leur indépendance
et leur liberté
mais on vous interroge
sur le fond parce que dans cette
intention il y a quand même
des des éléments qui montrent que in
fine est quand même cc c'est vous qui
avait le contrôle et ça me permet de
vous poser la dernière précisions sur ce
fonds au sein de votre faux pourquoi
avoir distingué v parts détenues dans le
monde elops désormais incessibles de
celles détenues dans nice-matin france
antilles et par étapes alors c'est pour
bien sûr je trouverais remet à sion la
finalité je n'ai jamais communiqué sur
ce fond c'est que sont les journaux le
pôle d'indépendance qui est communiqué
dessus moi vous ne verrez jamais avoir
fait une déclaration c'est aujourd'hui
la première fois que j'en parle et à
chaque fois que des journalistes nous
ont appelés eux m'ont appelée sur le
sujet j'ai toujours dit je n'en parle
pas ce n'est pas un sujet de
communication je vais pas vous dire que
j'ai fait un don de telles associations
telles fondations encore une fois l'idée
n'est pas prêt de faire de la
communication l'idée de ce fonds a été
de protéger la seule idée de ce fonds a
été de protéger le capital du monde le
capital du monde parce que
l'indépendance du monde elle est
protégée d'autres manières elle est
protégée à cinq niveaux et on va y aller
parce que c'est important 1 les
journalistes sont actionnaires le pôle
d'indépendance et actionnaire du journal
un peu moins de 30% le
bien sûr
[Musique]
non c'est
nous exposer de l'indépendance
rédactionnelle qui est séparé de
l'indépendance capitalistique et qui est
aussi très original mais met donc les
journalistes le pôle d'indépendance est
actionnaire ils ont un peu moins de 30%
du capital avec des droits fort ils ont
un tiers des sièges au conseil de
surveillance et le conseil de
surveillance un qui gère l'entreprise
ils ont un tiers des sièges au conseil
de surveillance et au même titre que
tous les autres actionnaires ils ont
accès à la stratégie totale et complète
de l'entreprise les sociétés de
rédacteurs dans tous les titres du
groupe le monde et après il faudra
prendre les autres journaux ou un droit
de veto sur la nomination du directeur
du journal ce droit de veto il est à 60%
on est dans un tout lv pas dans un truc
où globalement on a un consensus nous il
ya une charte des cris qui codifier les
droits et les devoirs un comité
d'éthique présidée par une ancienne
bâtonnière qui peut être saisie par
autant que besoin elle ne se prive pas
de se saisir le pôle d'indépendance
dipose d'un droit d'agrément si un
actionnaire souhaite devenir contrôlant
ou co-contrôle ans du groupe sans cet
agrément il peut pas y avoir de
changement de contrôle donc si vous
voulez à tous les étages à tous les
étages on a créé des choses il vous en
citer quelques-uns et vous pouvez en
trouver plus tous les étages cela existe
ensuite et je vous invite si vous voulez
en prendre part mais je voulais dit
trois gardes et le contenu du journal
regardez le contenu du journal il est
incroyablement
indépendant de ses actionnaires je suis
pas sûr que tous les gens que vous avez
pu
voir ces dernières ces derniers ajouts
blippar dont un truc très important vous
pourriez me dire on pourrait faire du
chantage sur le directeur de la
rédaction au travers de son salaire on a
créé un comité des rémunérations dont
fait partie julia cagé l'attendait donc
à tous les étages on le met et à chaque
fois qu'on a un doute sur un sujet moi
je sais au siècle pour l'indépendance et
on rajoute quelque chose en se disant si
un jour quelqu'un fait ça qu'est-ce qui
se passe et à chaque fois on crée ça
mais ça dans les statuts les statuts ne
peut pas être modifiée de par les
majorités nécessaires
et la présence au capital du pôle
d'indépendance donc si vous voulez
l'indépendance pratique du journal était
fait un jour on s'aperçoit que le sujet
capitalistique le changement de contrôle
n'a pas été bien réglé ce sujet on le
règle dont un peu dans l'urgence un peu
en difficulté et une règle et puis
au-delà dû régler ont créé un fonds en
disant bayane un des actionnaires du
monde un des actionnaires de contrôle du
monde qui craint une entité qui va
empêcher que ces titres soient cédés
fantastique et alliés dessus au lieu au
delà de ça parce que vous le faites dans
l'autre sens mais prônons dans mon sens
qu'est-ce qu'on rajoute on rajoute dans
ce truc là qui va contrôler ces bouts de
participation contrôlant du monde on va
commencer à faire entrer les
journalistes alors vous me dites
redonner tout journaliste c'est une
erreur moi j'ai non ces propos m'ont dit
vous n'êtes pas allé au bout du sujet
non aller au bout du sujet c'est
redonner je parlais tout à l'heure de
2 des statuts du fonds mais je vous
parle de la même chose mais j'ai dit
vous n'allez pas au fond du sujet en
donnant en tout aux journalistes ou
l'originalité des contrôles angers
dépendance absolue des titres ge et pas
seulement parler des rédactions non mais
si vous voulez dans le fond si
aujourd'hui vous dites je redonne le
contrôle total de cette participation
pour l'indépendance bien que vous
refaites l'erreur historique qui a fait
que les gens qui manage les entreprises
ne sont pas des gens qui savent faire
des journaux moi je ne sais pas faire
des journaux mais je sais gérer des
entreprises et voilà et c'est ce mélange
les deux choses qui fait que le monde
est rentable qui fait que le monde
explose en termes d'audience c'est ce
savoir faire partager un instant de
raison et si vous voulez si vous voulez
je viens ici et vous me dites c'est bien
ce que vous avez fait c'est sympa vous
n'êtes pas les enfants vous êtes petit
bras un je n'ai jamais communiquer là
dessus d'eux on est sur le chemin on y
va doucement je vous promets on avance
on va dans ce sens là on essaye de le
faire sur votre question pourquoi les
autres titres ne dispose pas du même des
mêmes droits ces choses ont été le sujet
de ceux de ce fonds a été discuté avec
le pôle d'indépendance
peut-être que le pôle d'indépendance à
la estime que le pôle d'indépendance du
monde peut-être que le pôle
d'indépendance du monde a estimé un
certain nombre de choses mais dans la
durée on corrigera sera bien évidemment
c'est on va ces quelques mots hier c'est
à d'évolutif
à dire la possibilité de cession de la
participation que j'ai dans un certain
nombre d'autres titres n'est pas prévue
aujourd'hui dans le fonds de dotation
mais ces titres aujourd'hui ne sont pas
dans le fond de teint d'accord là dessus
c'est pas
quelque chose de théoriser c'est une
étape et vous aussi non mais c'est
d'avancer d'accord vous laisser cette
possibilité ouverte moi j'ai une
dernière question sur même s'ils ont il
y en a beaucoup quand je regarde tout ce
que j'avais prévu mais on n'est qu'au
début parce que il y à mes collègues
vous faire sur la production etc mais
moi j'en ai une sur sur bien entendu
votre point de vue sur une autre
concentration parce que vous êtes très
actif
ici à chaque fois que les propriétaires
de médias n'étaient pas concernés
directement par la fusion tf1 m6 s'ils
nous disaient
je suis pas je suis pas content j'ai
rien à dire où je suis plutôt pour vous
connais votre position puisque vous avez
déjà réalisé quatre recours contre
l'éventuelle fusion outre tf1 m6 trois
des quatre ont été rejetées et la
dernière a été réalisée la semaine
dernière pour une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité
pouvez vous nous expliquer la raison de
tous ses recours en justice est votre
opinion sur ce dossier pas seulement
opinion comme citoyen mais comme acteur
concurrents deux de ces médias alors le
premier élément c'est que ces procédures
étaient liées quand même à une petite
spécificité une petite bizarrerie du cdu
déjà je me suis jamais expliqué ou
publiquement sur le sujet donc là pour
ça que je veux je remercie monsieur le
rapporteur beaucoup d'attention à ce que
vous allez dire que ce serait la
première fois que vous même
dit 7 cette expression
sur le fond du sujet donc ces recours le
principal recours était de contester
le déroulé le souhaitent déroulement de
cette procédure devant les autorités
françaises est bien mais vous ai plus
confiance dans votre pays la vérité de
vous dire un peu que nous on annonce
cette fusion qui quelque chose quand
même de lure d'incroyablement lourd dans
notre paysage et cette fusion sera
décidé par des autorités indépendantes à
paris cette fusion est à peine annoncé
que le président de l'art comme nous dit
tout va bien circulé on était censé être
auditionné avant même de nous avoir
auditionné tout va bien circuler la
ministre de la culture nous dit tout va
bien circuler la présidente de
l'autorité de la concurrence dit on va
garder elle est virée donc et à un
moment on se dit on n'est pas top top en
confiance vous pouvez nous dire elle est
virée vers le renouveler là on l'a
auditionné oui à différentes façons de
lire aimez vous votre point de vue c'est
que c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
n'est plus alors qu'elle souhaitait
continuer
qu'elle n'a pas été renouvelé écoutez
vous a été très directe direct on sait
qu'on fasse dès ce premier vous dérange
pas je vous est ce que vous confirmez
que c'est votre opinion mon opinion
personnelle sans avoir aucune forme
d'information me laisse penser qu'elle a
été virée liée à une absence de position
c'est-à-dire lié au fait qu'elle
souhaitait faire son boulot normalement
sur ce sujet et pour donner des exemples
on donne des exemples donc si vous
voulez à partir de ce moment là je ne
suis pas complètement confortable de me
dire mon pays est une grande démocratie
je crois dans sa justice mais parfois
dans ces autorités indépendantes
j'ai un petit doute quand le soutien de
cette opération qui est incroyablement
complexe en terme de concurrence
est soutenue par des gens qui
normalement devraient faire preuve d'un
peu plus de réserve
juste pour mieux comprendre votre pensée
là vous dit c'est pas la justice et ex
terrasses et des autorités indépendantes
vous avez parlé même d'actes de non
renouvellement or qui pour vous dire et
c'est aux autorités des pentes
puisqu'elles sont considérés comme
indépendants qui aurait intérêt de façon
de façon coordonnée puisqu'il ya
l'autorité la concurrence vous remettez
en cause l'art comme et son attitude qui
oui qui nettoie
les gens qui ont intérêt à être bien vus
ou bien soutenu dans ses médias tous les
gens qui ont vu qu'ils ont intérêt à
ménager bien avoir ce voeu ce pouvoir
sur ces autorités l'état accorde enfin
je crois enfin je ne sais pas qui nomme
les présidents sécurité je pense que le
sénat lui-même nomme un certain nombre
de membres de ces autorités qui ensuite
nomme le président donc si vous voulez
il ya un sujet collectif je ne sais pas
qui nomme à leurs chronos l autorité la
concurrence je ne sais pas qui choisit
le président je crois que c'est une
décision politique là dans ce cadre mais
si vous voulez stationné les l'état
c'est l'état c'est un chef d'état et
c'est un gouvernement donc vous nous
dites l'état de nous poursuivre et
poursuivre non non je vous en prie donc
si vous voulez à partir de ce moment là
on n'est absolument pas confortable à se
dire on va rester à paris avec un risque
d' intervention devant ces autorités
indépendantes et on a envie de quelque
chose de juste on a envie de quelque
chose de juste parce que ces deux
groupes sont ultra dominant en france
ultra dominant dans le fait de nous
amener de l'information et c'est ultra
domination normalement économique en
termes de pluralisme devrait
susciter un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui n'ont globalement
peu été suscitée si vous regardez assez
peu d'opposition à ce sujet là est assez
peu de position sur ce sujet là et donc
à partir de ce moment là le si vous
prenez la totalité de ce sujet vous
dites ok ces gens veulent fusionner
franchement pour le groupe tf1 c'est un
coût économique génial vous nous on est
quatre dans les télécoms on n'arrive pas
à passer à trois on pense qu'en
régulation les patients que ça puisse
passer un jour là à passer de deux
groupes privés dominant à un groupe
privé dominant près l'action d'un
monopole c'est un truc fantastique donc
c'est un coût économique et bravo aussi
des armes qu'ils y arrivent parce que
c'est un coût économique exceptionnelle
et je pense qu'ils le font uniquement
pour ça les autres problèmes c'est pas
leur sujet le sujet c'est des
commerçants des bons commerçants et les
bons commerçants ils veulent gagner de
l'argent et donc leur sujet c'est pas un
contrôle de du pluralisme de l'audience
ou de la publicité dans ce pays leur
idée c'est allons gagner de l'argent
pourquoi pas à partir de ce moment là
vous avez à vous interroger sur un
certain nombre de sujets
le premier élément qu'on va vous dire
ces groupes sont en grave difficulté ils
sont graves difficultés ça va très très
mal il risque de disparaître vous
prendriez une grande responsabilité
messieurs si vous ne soutenez pas cette
concentration grande responsabilité on
est à la limite de la menace écoutez moi
la grande responsabilité je sais pas où
aller donc on prend ces groupes les
chiffres sont assez claires je pense
qu'on peut voler faut les lire parce
qu'à un moment les chiffres de ces
groupes ils viennent de publier leurs
résultats ils sont très gentils ou les
incitait nous mêmes ouais non mais vous
allez voir c'est mieux que ce que vous
pensez et puisque l'on vous a on vous a
cité des groupes décident des chiffres
un peu réduit leur résultat net a
quasiment été doublé entre 2017 et 2021
158 millions de résultat net en 2010 7
280 dre des millions de résultat net
pour m6 en 2021 ga tf1 souleimane la
main en soi c'est pas normal de gagner
de l'argent sur les médias on y avait
même dit que c'était votre fut
entièrement d'accord avec vous monsieur
président des sciences est extrêmement
bien mais pas quand on veut se
concentrer parce que quand bien se
concentrer il faut une situation
exceptionnelle pour créer un monopole
dans un pays il faut une situation
exceptionnelle la création d'un monopole
et on va en parler après c'est
extrêmement bas donc ils n'ont pas de
problèmes financiers vous allez me dire
oui mais attendez ils ont un problème
d'audience disons un problème d'audience
un problème d'audience l'audience de tf1
en disant elle n'a pas bougé n'a pas
bougé l'audience de m6 en dix ans elle a
progressé ces deux groupes ont vu des
audiences pour un stabilisé et l'autre
progresser nous dit ouais mais quand
même il ya des friteries en train
d'arriver mais netflix n'est pas en
concurrence avec tf1 m6 et m6 est en
concurrence avec canal+ c'est un truc
payants contre un truc gratuit netflix à
10 millions d'abonnés en france canal en
a 9 millions je crois le chiffre
d'affaires canal et celui de supérieur
au chiffre d'affaires de netflix c'est
une blague c'est une vaste blague après
on va vous dire c'est youtube mais c'est
quoi youtube c'est des gens qui postent
leurs vidéos ça n'a rien à voir c'est
incomparable la publicité que vous allez
faire sur des médias digitaux c'est quoi
c'est un truc ultra ciblée c'est à dire
que je veux toucher les femmes de 55 ans
qui habite dans tel quartier c'est ça la
pub en digital la force de tf1 m6 c'est
une puissance s'est écrasé comment je
touche 10 millions de personnes comment
je mets mon spot dans hp y est je tousse
12 millions de personnes à un instant
donné c'est ça c'est cette force et
puissance il vous ai besoin de cette
force et puissance et elle est archi
nécessaire mais quand vous mettez ces
mêmes puissante il vous consolidez les
deux seuls médias qui ont ces puissances
en france vous créer des problèmes quels
problèmes vous crée les problèmes que
vous créez ils sont de différentes
natures vous créez un problème très
naturellement sur le marché de la
publicité le marché de la publicité ça
on l'a entendu non voulait pas entendu
de cette manière là je vais vous dire
quel est le vrai problème le vrai
problème de cette concentration c'est
que vous enlevez le la possibilité de
réguler les gars femmes et ça ça va
beaucoup plus loin que ce que l'on peut
dire on sera beaucoup plus un tronc peut
dire ça c'est un sujet majeur on ne
pourra plus régulé les gars fable si
vous allez au bout de cette
concentration et un deuxième truc et ce
serait déjà du mal à les réguler je sais
pas puisque madame le l'ancien président
de l'autorité de la concurrence a quand
même envoyé un pur à 100 millions de
condamnation juste monsieur r bien sûr
juste pour éclairer ce que ce que vous
suggérez da c'est quelque chose que j'ai
suggéré dans une audition c'est qu'à
part si on prend le marché pertinent
mêlant le numérique et le digital à ce
moment là la part ultra dominant
qu'avaient les gars femmes sur le marché
du numérique se diminue en pourcentage
et donc les régulations forte que qu'on
faisait quand ils étaient les seuls sur
le numérique ce ne seront plus les mêmes
puisqu'ils seront diluées dans une
proportion plus importante
l'ensemble des éléments du débat à cela
on ne répond que les 80 % de recettes
publicitaires détenus par google
facebook et maintenant un peu à la zone
ne sont pas du tout régulé donc
je pense qu'il faut pour étendre les
entendiez président l'autorité de la
concurrence oui je vous la posez la
question vous allez poursuivre mais mais
il ya quelque chose que vous me dites
pas dans votre réponse je vais pour que
vous l'intégrer à votre argumentation
c'est dans ces recours et dans cette
motivation vous avez beaucoup de passion
pour nous l'expliquer
c'est qu'est ce qu'est ce qui vous
dérange par rapport à vos propres
activités et jeux dans les deux sens
rapport à vos propres activités puisque
vous n'êtes pas dans la télévision en
concurrence sur ces 10 millions qui
veulent atteindre c'est donc sur la
téléphonie non non non non pas du tout
monsieur président financier pour iliad
mais il ya un risque financier colossal
pour yann c'est une augmentation du prix
on vous parle de 300 millions de
synergies on va les prendre là dessus je
pense qu on a 100 millions de synergies
c'est la hausse des prix la publicité et
ses 100 millions de marge et ça c'est un
truc qui touchent toutes mes activités
et donc si vous voulez en tant que
industriels j'ai cette problématique là
et c'est problématique là elle est pour
moi significative la hausse des prix de
la publicité elle est directe elle est
immédiate et et ça ne peut pas exister
autrement et je vous le redis
tf1 est la chaîne la plus puissante
d'europe en terme d'audience m6 la
chaîne la plus rentable d'europe c'est
ça le truc c'est ça la réalité on vous
dit parfois regardé aux états unis tout
le monde à consolider la première chaîne
de télévision américaine à 7% d'audience
y en a plein d network aux us donc si
vous voulez en termes de publicité vous
allez pardon créé un monstre qui va
dominer ce marché est en fait qu on est
en train de vous dire c'est que le
marché de la publicité
ces marchés du temps de cerveau
disponible parce que c'est quoi la
logique de mettre les mots clés sur
google dans ce même marché c'est quoi le
bon coup mais pas la presse au passage
beaucoup mais pas la presse pour qu'on
m'ait pas l'affichage pour qu'on met pas
tout et au bout on est en train de vous
dire notre marché c'est le temps de
cerveau disponible c'est le temps de
cerveau sur lequel vous avez des trucs
et dans lequel on va vous mettre de la
publicité et ça c'est un sujet
incroyablement problématique parce que
c'est une hausse des prix et en tant
qu'industriel je vais avoir cette hausse
des prix parce que je ne peux pas me
passer de tf1 je peux pas me passer m6
dans la publicité et à partir de ce
moment là sur ce sujet là je suis
attaqué je distribue ses chaînes c'est
quand même un truc fantastique ce sont
des chaînes gratuites mais nous les
rémunérer aujourd'hui nous avons ces
deux groupes ce sont les deux seuls
groupes à qui nous payons les chaînes
linéaires gratuites sont des chaînes
gratuites
on leur achète
demain aujourd'hui je peux couper une de
ses chaînes nous avons coupé bfm un
moment on avait il souhaité nous faire
payer nous n'avons pas souhaité payer on
a coupé des fn le groupe vivendi a coupé
et tf1 à un moment où on souhaitait les
faire payer ou n'ont pas sauté payer
mais qui aura le courage de couper tf1
et m6 en même temps parce que dans votre
négociation ils voudront imposer quelque
chose d'inacceptable personnes donc en
tant que distributeur la télévision vous
en ai parlé au travers d box triple play
le premier ou deuxième en france je suis
touchée dans cette activité là puisque
je risque de disparaître dans cette
activité la troisième activité en termes
de production du visuel producteurs
audiovisuels quand vous produisez quand
le média one produit un film comme bac
nord bac nord il ya d un certain nombre
d'endroits vous aller collecter des
recettes vous allez voir tf1 et m6 pour
poser vos questions pour leur dire
combien vous mettez-vous tf1 et m6 pour
financer sa et bien partir de ce moment
là la même manière vous n'avez pu ce
marché ouvert et ses quatre mille
producteurs qui sont en france vont
souffrir certains vont disparaître et
pourtant ces producteurs ils ont fait le
boulot que n'ont pas fait tf1 m6 tf1 et
m6 sont restés tf1 notamment il restait
un groupe français local bertelsmann est
fait vous lourd en commençant à avoir la
distribution partout c'est quoi le
secret netflix je produis un contenu je
le dis falls dans le monde entier c'est
ça le truc c'est pas parce que vous
allez relier tf1 et m6 demain que vous
allez avoir mis leurs productions ça va
être exactement l'inversé savait
exactement inverse ils vont négocier la
production moins cher au contraire vous
allez faire baisser lequel la qualité de
cette production et tout ça nous amène à
des choses problématique mais je vous
rajoute le sujet parce que c'est le
sujet de cette commission le pluralisme
je voulais dit tout à l'heure un article
du monde il est lui pas cent mille
personnes un bon article du monde il y
eut par 110 personnes tous les soirs tf1
20 heures cinq à six millions de
personnes 19 45 m6 trois millions et
demi de personnes vous rajoutez rtl
c'est quoi la puissance du monde face à
la puissance du groupe tf1 et six réunis
c'est un rapport de 1 à 100 et je pense
que vous avez quelque chose là qui est
extrêmement important ce qui est
important de réguler c'est pas la
concentration dans le sens des gens
récupèrent des médias les agrège etc
c'est quelle est votre part quel est
votre puissance dans la diffusion
d'informations à l'instant de raison
quelle est la puissance et votre foi là
dedans parce que ça c'est là où ils
danger pour la démocratie si un instant
de raison
étirements
aussi détient sans papiers très opposés
à la fusion passionnément si c'est pas
gentil de me couper monsieur le
président je me voir mais c'est super je
ne suis pas sur une liste de questions
de sénateurs qui va nous poser le jeu
lui demander alors finissez votre propre
au but mais je vous ai coupé les donc je
prendrais pour le plus rageant parce
qu'on a des questions à vous poser le
pluralisme surtout sur une chaîne comme
tf1 qui dans l'histoire a montré que le
pluralisme était un sujet on va dire
complexe et le lancement de free mobile
un jour je ne sais pas pourquoi tf1
oubliez donc heureusement d'autres
médias se sont moqués d'eux et à la fin
ils ont fini par en parler trois
secondes sur leurs antennes on a rendu
des dizaines de milliards pouvoir de de
dizaines de milliards d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat aux français collectivement mais
part de l'existence de free mobile donc
on arrive là dessus et c'est l'effet
oublie d'en parler et c'est le quotidien
dans le cadre de la fusion m6 tf1 m6
vous dit un truc pourri sur tf1 vous non
plus vous inviter chez tf1 vous n'êtes
plus invité vaucher lci et ces
puissances ce poids incroyable rumeu
vous verrez jamais vous m'auriez vu sont
toutes les antennes de france jamais ni
chez tf1 nicher et si jamais ça n'existe
pas que j'aie jamais reçu une invitation
de la vie et pourtant vous avez des
interviews de martin bouygues le monde
wire si vous voulez ses conceptions des
médias elle les problématiques et quand
vous donner plus de puissance pour le
pluralisme c'est un problème bien que je
pense je vous dis c'est une très belle
opération pour qui prendra le contrôle
de l'ensemble félicitations c'est une
super opération économique je pense que
pour nous en tant qu'industriels et en
tant que citoyen c'est un énorme
problème est que ça ne tient pas alors
réellement une le choc d'une
vérification par des autorités
indépendantes une des conséquences
possibles de la fusion tf1 m6 serait la
remise sur le marché d'un certain nombre
de chaînes en vertu de l'application de
la loi 2 2 86e tf1 et m6 ont évoqué
sister tf1 série séries films tfx ou
google y est ce que angie votre
structure dans les médias ou média one
donc vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
serait intéressé par reprendre une ou
plusieurs de ses chaînes mais à partir
du moment où je pense que ça ne peut pas
exister je le sujet ne se pose pas je
pense je pense pas dans ce sens je vous
laisse lire le jeu peut être que média
où elle regarde je ne sais pas mais à
l'instant vous ne regardez pas attractif
non pas aujourd'hui ça me paraît
tellement aberrant que si vous voulez je
ne peux même pas me projeter dans ce
monde monique de marco
bon ça vous paraît tellement aberrant
que vous vous imaginez pas que une
fusion puisse faire
voilà donc c'est très intéressant les
arguments que vous avez développé vous
êtes
et on a déjà soulevé ses arguments
concernant la publicité l'impact sur la
production audiovisuelle précédemment
dans les auditions je reviens sur les
propos justement a tenu hier lors de
l'audition comité d'éthique richard
michel comité d'éthique de canal+ qu'il
nous disait qu'il fallait dans la loi
donc mieux spécifier ce que c'est que le
pluralisme dont vous avez parlé
donc j'aimerais bien que vous nous
disiez un petit peu ce que c'est pour
vous le pluralisme et internet j'ai pas
terminé je profite pour avoir notre
question pensez vous et ça aussi c'est
et des sujets que nous avons abordés
lors des auditions qu'il faut modifier
les aides à la presse et dans quel sens
et j'ai une dernière question parce
qu'on n'a pas abordé le sujet du rachat
et donc du groupe la provence
donc je sais pas si vous pensiez le
faire mais moi je juste je reviens sur
quelques éléments sur ce rachat vous
aviez ans pour cent
et vous souhaitez avait fait donc
répondu à l'appel d'offres etc
parallèlement nous avons eu des retours
donc de syndicats de personnels donc de
la provence qui s'inquiétaient justement
de votre offre en conséquence de ce qui
s'est passé quand vous avez repris donc
france antilles et france guyane où il
n'y a plus aujourd'hui donc d'impression
et de diffusion donc du journal papier
en guyane pouvez vous donc nous préciser
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé sur
france antilles et francebillet excusez
moi mais oubliez votre première question
est ma première question c'est est
d'après vous qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que le pluralisme non non je
vous remercie je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui va probablement vous choquer
je m'en excuse mais moi je ne suis pas
choqué par ces news je suis pas choqué
par ces news c'est une chaîne d'opinion
je vous plains doute là dessus une shon
d'opinion
maintenant vous avez 30 % des français
est visiblement semble bloquée sur
l'unique est assez proche de cette
chaîne d'opinion c'est interdit
normalement les chaînes d'opinion net je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous donc
c'est le travail de l'arcade
maintenant si leur comme fait pas son
travail c'est pas mon sujet ou est ce
que j'ai à dire je encore une fois ça me
renforce dans les petits doutes donc je
ne vais pas me laisser cette somme c'est
quand même étonnant parce que avec
beaucoup de passion vous avez expliqué
pourquoi tf1 m6
c'était pas bien la fusion est là alors
que vous reconnaissez manifestement
qu'il ya une contravention avec les
conventions passées avec l'art comme
vous minimisez vous dites maintenant je
cherche pas à minimiser c'est une chaîne
d'opinion
sauf que celle existant en vous disant
ça c'est une forme de provocation et
j'en suis complètement conscient je vous
dis juste que le pluralisme c'est
d'avoir des médias qui soit capable de
s'adresser à tout le monde on a besoin
de médias qui s'adresse à tous parce que
si vous n'avez pas de médias qui
s'adresse à tout le monde des médias
d'opinion on a un sujet et puis on a
besoin de médias d'information mais on a
besoin de tout ça pour avoir une
démocratie qui fonctionne et c'est quoi
le pluralisme c'est la capacité d'avoir
un panorama dans les médias qui
représente qui nous sommes nous avec nos
opinions nos différences et le risque
c'est la concentration
de quelque chose de pas considérer de
mainstream à un endroit donné mais c'est
ça qui m'inquiète et encore une fois
vous pouvez avoir un homme médias qui
représente 50 60 % de l'audience en
france et puis une multitude de petits
de petits médias qui représente 0 1 2 0
1 % l'audience est au bout du bout ce
qui me met
incroyablement mal à l'aise et j'y
reviens c'est toutes les concentrations
qui vont tous est un groupe à avoir une
audience incroyable je vous ai donné les
chiffres et je vais pas vous leur donnez
ce que vous allez en avoir marre mais le
poids et la puissance d'un certain
nombre de médias
ne peut pas être comparée à celle du
monde de ces news ou d'autres médias au
delà du non respect potentiel de la
convention et c'est un sujet quand une
fois d'arkham on peut le retirer leur
fréquence ils ne respectent pas leurs
obligations c'est pas un sujet on est
une petite fée six sites cités je prends
votre point c'est que ces fréquences
sont gratuites ces fréquences de
télévision sont gratuites nous dans les
télécoms on les paye très cher au
travers de d'enchères peut-être qu'à un
moment on pourrait peut-être aussi faire
des enchères pour les chaînes de
télévision et savoir ce serait peut-être
pas complètement idiot le budget de
l'état je pense ne ne se refuserait pas
ça surtout si on se rapproche vers un
sujet de monopole donc le pluralisme ces
dates de donner la capacité de ne pas se
retrouver à un moment avec quelque chose
de trop fort qui soit mono politique et
essayer d'autres c'est la part de marché
de chacun de ces médias qui est
importante pas leur nombre alors non
c'est pas leur nombre est important ce
qui est important c'est leur part de
marché à chacune sur la manière dont une
des ligues de l'information sur le temps
où il nous délivre de l'information donc
ça c'est l'élément pour moi qui me
paraît le plus important sur les sujets
des aides à la presse alors il une forme
de petit fantasme je crois que le monde
a touché 2 millions d'euros directement
de dallas presse souvent les médias sont
les les récepteurs de ces aides pour les
redistribuer à france messagerie et à
d'autres donc le monde sauf en a par le
groupe le monde le monde croit que
c'était 2 millions d'euros
2,2 de 2,2
dead à la presse
il coûtait les fils et les choses là se
joue donc sur vingt et quelques millions
de résulte de résultats tant mieux pour
eux je suis content pour le monde alors
ces aides il ya un certain nombre de
sujets qu'il faudrait voir et prendre à
bras le corps on en a parlé tout à
l'heure monsieur le sénateur c'est
france messagerie le fait d'avoir
plusieurs distributeurs de une presse
papier qui est bien évidemment avec
l'otan va continuer de diminuer en
termes de volumes bien certain nombre de
sujets à traiter mais la plupart des
aides perçues sont destinés à être
ensuite reversée à d'autres d'autres
éléments sur le groupe france antilles
et plus particulièrement france guyane
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on s'est
retrouvé à un moment où la société le
groupe france antilles a été liquidée
tout le temps toute la presse française
a dit on va avoir des repreneurs on va
trouver des repreneurs on va retrouver
des repreneurs ok et puis un jour je lis
dans le journal ce journal se sait
liquider ces liquides et ouais france
antilles et liquides et c'est le seul
titre de presse locale dans les antilles
en guyane c'est le seul titre qui existe
c'est le seul groupe qui existe et là je
me dis c'est pas possible et donc on
arrive à avoir une procédure avec le
tribunal a trouvé une procédure
dérogatoire pour sortir la liquidation
c'est à dire que des salariés qu'ils
étaient licenciés on va les rechercher
en leur disant mais revenez on part
relancer le groupe on va le crès et on
recrée cette aventure incroyable au
passage on relance le titre en papier en
martinique et en guadeloupe on n'y est
pas encore en guyane on n'est qu'en
digital en guyane mais on y travaille et
on va essayer de revenir aussi là parce
que je pense que dans ces territoires où
le la notion de fake news est
incroyablement plus forte à celle que
nous pouvons constater ici on a besoin
de ces journaux on a besoin de créer ces
médias et qu'au bout d'un an c'est ma
responsabilité mais notre responsabilité
d'avoir des médias qui
elle vend sont capables de diffuser une
information vérifiée contrôlés par des
journalistes qui sont capables de la
delà de l'apprendre de l'analyser et de
la ressortir jeu le vraiment la notion
de fait knut dans ces territoires est
incroyablement élevé et il faut vraiment
bossé sur le sujet
sur la provence le sujet la provence et
deux suivants c'est que quand j'ai
repris le contrôle de nice matin nice
matin d'une manière générale nice matin
et la provence avait été financée par un
groupe qui s'appelle à des
développements qui appartenait au
gouvernement belge et qui a financé le
plus ou moins sauver ces deux groupes
ainsi qu'au corps ce matin qu'ils
avaient sauvé plus ou moins ces trois
groupes donc le ces groupes se
retrouvait dans la difficulté et au sein
de cette entité il y avait deux
participations minoritaires sel dans
nice matin et celle dans et dans la
provence et comme dans les deux cas il y
avait eu d un certain nombre de 2,2
pacte qui avait été passé qui permettait
à terre de prendre le contrôle de ces de
ces médias ça s'est fait dans nice matin
et maintenant ça sera pour la provence
juste une précision sur la réponse vous
avez apporté sur les aides à la presse
vous avez donné le chiffre de 2 millions
nets pour le monde oui c'est à dire
bouger plus et à 106,3 pourvoi de groupe
comment et 6 millions 1,3 pour
l'ensemble des titres doit s'endetter
touiza est donné c'est pour le monde je
suppose que je sais pas j'ai vu son
chiffre à l'heure dans mes notes je
voulais retrouver je vous le redis
merci monsieur le président monsieur
niel vous ai déjà répondu beaucoup de
questions que je vais envisager de vous
poser mais
de jeu partir sur la presse sur les
journalistes vous avez déjà créé
plusieurs écoles dont la dernière
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines à lévis est non est ce que vous
envisagez de créer un jour une école de
journalistes puisque aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de l'indépendance des
journalistes d'ailleurs j'ai lu dans
libération que vous ce que vous auriez
déclaré un jeu mais quand même ceci au
conditionnel quand les journalistes
m'emmerde jeu prend une participation
dans leurs canards et ensuite il me
foute la paix je voulais savoir si
c'était votre conception de la de
l'indépendance des journalistes et de
leurs libertés et puis pour revenir sur
quelque chose un peu plus précis aussi
un de vos confrères préconise la
taxation des plates formes en fonction
du débit de bande passante et qu'elles
jugeront chez les opérateurs est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée
alors sur votre première question on va
enfin on va essayer de continuer de
créer merci d'évoquer cette cette école
en fait l'idée c'est à dire on peut
avoir des entrepreneurs qui viennent
dans l'agriculture et l'idée c'est de
créer dans cette idée c'est de se dire
comment on
comment on arrive à former c'est
que l'on arrive à former ces jeunes il
leur apprendre un métier et je trouve
que quand vous avez des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui sont en quête de sens sont à
la recherche de quelque chose
l'agriculture c'est un truc fantastique
et toutes formes d'agriculture de
l'élevage sont lacombe a fait porter des
idées genre je veux tuer le monde animal
faire que de la viande végétal moi je
mange de la viande du pâtis mais si vous
voulez l'idée c'est comme on est capable
de former ces agriculteurs de pousser
des jeunes notamment de région
parisienne faire l'agriculture en les
aidant à créer un métier
j'ai un problème je suis sous serment et
si je vous raconte quelque chose de faux
c'est cinq ans de prison
essayez on verra
je suis incroyablement ennuyés parce que
je ne sais pas quoi faire je n'ai jamais
dit cette phrase
maintenant je mets des tracts oui je
sais bien mais j'en doute pas et c'est
dans un livre on va en parler mes
détracteurs mais mes concurrents me
laffont toujours portés et et je vous
avouerai ça me fait tellement plaisir de
leur faire plaisir que je suis obligé de
continuer de soutenir que les 10 alors
je suis un peu gêné rigide ans mais je
les dis on sait plus quoi inventer à
chaque fois malheureusement je suis
sensé de l'avoir dit d'après un livre au
fondateur du vin que vous eric fottorino
qui c'est génial c'est un journal
fantastique je suis censé l'avoir dit à
eric fottorino en tête à tête le
problème c'est que même heureux eric
fottorino le dit il n'a jamais dit ça
c'est très très gênant
maintenant je
franchement ça me fait tellement de
peine de vous la nied donc ce que je
vous propose et de manière dérogatoire
si ça pouvait ne pas être mis au compte
rendu cette séance pour laisser mes
détracteurs continuer de le dire
franchement donc je suis désolé vous
demander quelque chose de dérogatoire
aujourd'hui mais c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable mes concurrents
régulièrement la cites vous ne vous en
supplie vous n'avez pas la d re sur le
rapporteur il ya un peu pitié un peu de
pitié monsieur le pouvoir du président
tant mieux je ne sais plus quoi fédérer
en fonction des réponses que vous
apporterez la suite de nos questions je
vous en remercie pour votre je sais que
vous avez un coeur monsieur le président
la dernière question était sur la
première question met pas tout à fait
répondu sur la première question sur
l'école du journalisme est ce que vous
avez dit excusez moi j'étais parti sur
la lecture en faites-vous non c'est
aussi vrai que le département des
yvelines de mes chers mais km mais passe
à borgu
non sur le département sur le
département des yvelines non sur l'école
de journalistes je crois que c'est des
des sujets qui sont évoqués au monde le
la nouvelle directrice du de l'ops
elle même bien d'une était une ancienne
dirigeante d'une école de journalisme et
je crois que l'idée c'est de se dire est
ce qu'on n'est pas capable de créer une
école sur l'investigation
l'investigation c'est super important
dans la presse si vous êtes un
globalement si vous avez une idée un peu
particulière de la gestion de vos médias
faire l'investigation sait jamais une
bonne nouvelle je suis franchement si
vous prenez j'étais l'actionnaire ravi
mediapart ça a été une opération
financière incroyable avec les limiers
tous les fondateurs vous étiez
actionnaires de magna pas ouais
fondateur et disent qu'ils le disent que
vous n'était pas actionnaire mais je ne
suis aujourd'hui non mais même à
l'origine que vous avez apporté une
participation exactement monsieur de la
même manière je ne suis pas actionnaire
du monde je suis actionnaire du holding
je suis même plus actionnaire du monde
puisqu'on va dans un fonds de dotation
donc j'étais actionnaire du monde au
travers d'une holding au monde et dans
cette holding on a été investi sans
risque parfois un peu gêné mais je crois
qu'on a fait quatre ou cinq fois notre
argent et les fondateurs donc c'était
plutôt une très belle opération
financière plutôt bien ce qui n'a jamais
empêché mediapart de gentiment
régulièrement de faire des articles plus
ou moins juste à mon avis et en toute
liberté et de continuer de le faire et
vous savez quoi je pense qu'on a besoin
de mediapart dans ce pays parce qu'on a
besoin d'investigation alors il faut que
l'investigation ça soit bien fait quand
vous la faites comme archi l'a fait
c'est un garçon sérieux raisonnable il
va chercher son information il apprend
qui la publie parfois dans les
historiques de mediapart c'est un peu
plus particulier mais vous avez une
jeune génération qui ont envie de faire
l'investigation est souvent les discuter
de ça au monde en se disant est ce qu on
est on est ce qu'on ne devrait pas formé
plus de gens pour faire l'investigation
parce que l'investigation c'est quand
même le coeur de ce métier
et en général si vous voulez avoir une
vie tranquille vous ne faites pas
d'investigation dans des journaux c'est
une vie tranquille mais l'investigation
c'est la chose la plus importante c'est
la chose qui permet de découvrir ce que
l'on cherche à cacher dans les grands
groupes que vous allez l'additionner y
en a plus par qui et qui ont fait
disparaître un huissier sont ils en
veulent plus c'est ennuyeux louvre ça
fait des problèmes et je pense que c'est
exactement l'inversé qui va faire
fonctionner nos journaux c'est d'être
capable de faire d'investigation donc je
crois que le monde a pour projet d'aller
dans ce sens là vous surtout sur
l'investigation et j'avais posé de
troisième question sur la taxation sous
la dent deux passantes pour rodez c'est
un sujet super compliqué
ce qui concerne beaucoup de trafic
aujourd'hui ne sont pas ceux qui étaient
là hier je vais le faire à l'envers je
pense qu'il doit aider ou favoriser ceux
qui ont très peu d'audience plutôt que
de taxer les gros donc à nous d'être
intelligents ont peut-être dans l'autre
sens mais l'importance de l'internet et
de la gratuité sur internet est pour moi
la capacité en fait il ya un truc
fantastique avec l'émergence d'internet
c'est que ça a permis à tout le monde de
créer des meilleurs et quand vous payez
votre compte twitter nos comptes twitter
sont des médias en soit c'est une des
médias qui ne représente que nous mais
ce sont des médias en soi et j'ai
toujours trouvé ça
incroyablement important d'auxi que vous
commencez à taxer ça veut dire vous
commencez si vous le faites pas
intelligemment vous commencez à censurer
je suis toujours très mal à l'aise sur
ces sujets parce que je pense que
internet est un lieu incroyable de
liberté ce qui n'empêche pas des vérifs
mais c'est un lieu incroyable de liberté
et il faut le laisser incroyablement lit
parce que si vous commencez à taxer la
bande passante à un moment on serait
capable de taxe est celui d'un service
parce que l'on trouve que ce service ne
correspond pas à ses propres aux idées
ou à ses propres pensées alors avant de
passer la parole à sylvie robert qui va
du coup je préparais ma j'avais une
question à vous poser est ce que vous
pourriez nous confirmer avoir été
candidat au rachat de m6 rtl
pas directement
monsieur le président mais oui tout à
fait comme dit pas directement c'est à
dire c'est à dire au travers de ces
encore une fois je me suis associé dans
de nombreuses sociétés dans ces sociétés
incertain une de ces sociétés avaient un
intérêt pour l'achat tf1 m6 avec
d'autres partenaires oui média one d les
actionnaires média one et une partie de
média one oui
bonjour monsieur niel bonjour d'abord je
voulais vous remercier pour la clarté de
vos propos j'aurai trois questions alors
la première dans la continuité de celle
de ma collègue monique de marco
votre intérêt sur pour le projet de
rachat la provence est il un intérêt
pour la presse régionale
ce que vous avez envie de poursuivre vos
investissements dans ce segment de la
presse ça c'est ma première question la
deuxième j'avais posé une question à
monsieur de rallye alors vous allez
sûrement me faire la même réponse mais
je vous la repose je lui avais parlé de
l'idée d'un rapprochement entre iliad et
altice et d'ailleurs au détour d'un de
vos propos tout à l'heure vous avez dit
oh ça va être compliqué comme on vous
l'avait dit passer de quatre opérateurs
à 3 finalement un tel rapprochement
serait une bonne idée selon vous non ça
c'est ma deuxième question est ma
dernière question avec média one vous
faites partie des leaders européens de
production et distribution de contenu on
le sait les huit plus grands groupes
américains vont investir en france
environ 172 milliards d'euros d'ici 2025
avez-vous à l'intention de poursuivre
cette stratégie d'acquisitions
d'intégration en tout cas de contenu et
de notamment de studio à votre groupe
est ce que vous avez envie d'étendre
média one par exemple dans la musique
dans le jeu dans le jeu vidéo dans le
métavers ce en quelque sorte quelle est
votre stratégie
et avez vous une ligne éditoriale pour
la production notamment en termes de
documentaires ou de fiction voilà je
vous remercie beaucoup pour vos réponses
merci non le
le sujet c'est toujours encore une fois
avec cette vision industrielle c'est de
se dire à quel endroit vous avez des
actifs qui prennent un risque de
disparaître ou qui risquent de ne pas
rester indépendant de les regarder et de
se dire est ce qu'on est capables nous
de faire quelque chose et de créer de la
valeur de créer des groupes qui soit
rentable dans la durée avec cette double
volonté c'est de l'assuré un une
indépendance des rédactions et une
indépendance économique encore une fois
ce n'est pas la volonté ce n'est jamais
d'avoir des danseuses parce que les
danseuses c'est des histoires qui
prennent on a toujours un risque et ça
ce terminal c'est toujours cette volonté
d'être indépendant
c'est cette indépendance c'est une
question que c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous ai pas répondu le vous regardiez
les horizontales verticales je crois
qu'un personne que vous avez entendu que
vous avez parlé vous parler de jeux
d'échecs il est faussement naïve et
c'est bien mais le point est le suivant
c'est que quand vous mettez dans le même
groupe physiquement quand vous avez les
mêmes personnes pour diriger pour poreux
pour avoir des activités qui
potentiellement vives de grands contrats
d'état vous êtes un problème si vous
êtes dans l'armement si vous êtes dans
btp et que vous vivez de ces gros
contrats disposer dans la même dans la
même surface financière d'un d'un média
c'est un problème dans les télécoms je
crois que patrick groulx l'avait dit non
vie de des enchères et des appels
d'offres mais donc
excusez moi c'est un peu je sors un peu
de votre question est donc le sujet
c'est comment on est capable cinéma
significativement de garder cette presse
régionale en fonctionnement rentable se
développant on avec une indépendance
économique et une indépendance
financière et pas encore une fois pas
créer des danseuses le fonds de dotation
il est pas là pour créer une danseuse il
est là pour avoir des médias rentable
qui pour des siècles et des siècles vont
continuer d'exister pour continuer
d'évoluer et vont être capables de
générer de l'argent pour réussir à aller
dans ce sens-là sur le rapprochement il
y a altiste comme tout bon commerçant si
on peut passer de 80 où je suis pour
surtout si je suis là d'ailleurs ont
toutes franchi donc bah je c'est pour ça
que je peux pas vous dire du mal de des
commerçants bertelsmann et bouygues ce
sont des commerçants et en tant que
commerçant voilà en tant que client ou
en tant qu'utilisateur ou en tant que
citoyen je peux avoir un avis différent
mais là comme vous poser ma question en
tant que commerçants jeu
j'ai du mal à vous faire une réponse
autres mais ça en effet ça posera
certain nombre de problèmes je vous
écoute excusez mon madame non je disais
derrière je pensais bien d'autres
séquences comme vous mais en tant que
citoyenne est
innocent je vais m'abstenir
révéler les conséquences potentiellement
auquel je penserai en tant que citoyens
ce qui est toujours un sujet
problématique mais
en effet et donc il faudrait des remèdes
et des eaux mais de forts et on parle
que d'un passage de 4 à 3 et que pour ça
que quand on compare avec d'autres cas
on se dit que tout est ouvert si la
france doit être qu'un regroupement de
grands monopoles alors là on se plaint
peut-être déjà de la concentration des
richesses et la fortune entre un nom
demain trop restreint en france là on
peut tout imaginer ça serait un truc
fantastique bon donc c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il ya quand même un certain
nombre de sujets sur média one
le
il ya un truc fou c'est que tous ces
producteurs sont là
ils ont besoin d'être aidés pour
justement pouvoir vendre leurs contenus
assez assez notamment à ces américains
je crois que vous avez reçus ici trois
grands groupes et c'est trois grands
groupes
ils français plus vous avez reçu ici se
développe à l'international et l'idée
c'est oui sur média one de continuer
pierre antoine capton qui dirige ce
groupe c'est un boulot incroyable
fantastique encore une fois c'est une
idée qu'on a eue il ya quatre ans avec
matthieu pigasse et lui tous les trois
on est quatre ans après
il a acheté 70 entreprises de production
audiovisuelle le
60 des entités qui sont restés
indépendante qui se développe
et qui bénéficie juste d'une aide pour
avoir de l'argent financer des choses et
aller
plus loin donc ce truc et est
incroyablement
important et encore une fois avec une
avec une liberté éditoriale parce que
c'est pour ça que ça marche on n'a pas
cette liberté éditoriale ça va pas
marcher et ça va pas fonctionner et oui
bien sûr on fait déjà des jeux vidéo je
crois qu'il ya des sujets sur la musique
je vous le verrez cet été je crois qu'il
ya un truc fantastique sur la musique
peut-être un jour sur le but adverse ça
dépend de nos clients et on sera ravi je
suis sûr que média one sera ravie de
produire des contenus pour ses clients
a demandé de placer la parole aux
rapporteurs pour une dernière question
mais j'avais trois questions à vous
poser les deux premières vont être brève
vous
m'avez dit en propos introductif que
j'avais omis de dire vous aviez créé un
journal à 20 ans quel était ce jour date
un journal humoristique c'est un journal
drôle et puis après à partir de l'âge de
21 22 ans j'ai dit et des des journaux
d'information boursière
voilà puis j'ai continué là dessus et
encore une fois je vous ai dit je les
fais dans dans tous les sens je vous ai
senti choqué tout à l'heure quand je
vous ai dit que
j'étais pas choqué par ces news chez
news c'est potentiellement une chaîne
aux femmes j'ai été très choqué par le
fait que vous disiez ça j'ai choqué
parce que j'étais choqué par le fait que
vous avez utilisé le terme télé
d'opinion alors que la télé d'opinion
n'existe pas en france oui parce que les
soumises enfin elle elle existe mais pas
sur des fréquences hertziennes mais
encore une fois
en tant que citoyen je conteste la
xénophobie le racisme c'est tout
l'inversé de ma vie c'est vous irez vers
ce rêve de ma vie mais au bout il ne
faut jamais museler les opinions c'est
ça mon sujet nous jamais amusé les
oppida excusez moi juste pour pas que il
ya des confusions il y à des chaînes
d'information il peut y avoir des
chaînes d'opinion où il pas sur le
hertzien par contre nul part dans ce
pays
dans les lois de ce pays le racisme est
considérée comme une opinion mais comme
un délit donc essayons au moins nous
d'être clair canton nanan mes opinions
pas opinion chez puis il ya le reste il
chante même si le rapporteur je crois
qu'on est sur le fond entièrement
d'accord et je m'en excuse c'est
probablement ma forme ou la forme dont
j'ai pu vous le dire qui pose problème
et sujet
de il n'est pas tolérable d'avoir des
chaises des contenus ou des médias
xénophobes ou racistes dans ce pays et
mon interprétation n'est pas une
interprétation
fermé c'est une interprétation large
quand vous êtes sur un média et vous
tenez des propos racistes ou xénophobes
même par ambiguïté il faut vous
condamnez
ça c'est mon premier élément maintenant
vous avez des gens qui ont des avis qui
votent sur des sujets et on a besoin de
médias qui répondent à leurs questions
leurs envies à leurs ambitions à leurs
opinions et ça c'est incroyablement
important je comprends que ça ne peut
pas exister sur les chaînes hertziennes
mais la liberté est quelque chose que je
pense qu'au cours de ces dix dernières
années on a eu des tonnes de loi qui ont
restreint aux libertés layton de loi qui
restreint la liberté et je pense que ce
sujet là c'est un sujet démocratique
incroyablement important il faut que
tout le monde puisse dire ce qu'il a
envie de dire il faut que tout le monde
soit condamné s'il tient des propos
qui portent atteinte à d'autres qui sont
des nobles qui sont racistes il s'agit
pas de défendre la chaîne en elle même
quand il connaît des camps l'aï dit il
s'agit de défendre l'existence de médias
d'opinion qui correspondent un certain
nombre de français
la deuxième question vous avez dit que
vous aviez des jaunes qui vont de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite
quels sont les journaux d'extrême droite
jeu s'est passé d'extrême droite parce
que je peux être que les jeux
typiquement je suis actionnaire de
causeur de manière
historique et c'est un journal qui
défend sa liberté je ne crois pas a été
condamné à ce jour par user xénophobie
racisme et peut-être et je n'espère pas
mais je vais était actionnaire de ce
journal à un moment à sa création je
suis là cette participation est là mais
ce n'est pas pour autant la ligne
éditoriale c'est à un moment ce journal
avait besoin d'exister
j'ai été ravi mettre un petit peu
d'argent dedans et les aider d
accompagner je n'en suis pas contre
olemps ça avance et c'est là mais encore
une fois
cette liberté me paraît incroyablement
importante et je pense qu'elle se doit
d'être aidé je comprends que c'est
souvent une discussion qu'on avait avec
des des journalistes médias
on parle de ses news assez classique et
ils disent mais comment comment vous
pouvez dire ça je dis ça parce que je le
pense je pense que notre liberté elle se
doit d'être défendue elle se doit d'être
défendus et donc la liberté de tout à
chacun d'avoir des opinions contraires
c'est important c'est ce qui forme le
débat et c'est ce qui forme la
démocratie et souvent c'est quelque
chose qu'on a oublié et donc on va les
pouvoirs la concentration de ceci de
cela on y voyant un problème ou un sujet
et le vrai sujet c'est ce que vous vous
disiez madame tout à l'heure madame la
sénatrice c'est le pluralisme est ce
qu'on a des gens qui représentent tous
les avis et c'est ça qui est important
et est-ce qu'on n'a pas un endroit donné
quelque chose d'incroyablement similaire
qui ne correspond pas à ce que sont les
français à ce que nous sommes dernière
question dont on va faire vous avez dit
tout à l'heure et c'est un point
important pour notre combat
pour notre compréhension de l'écosystème
que vous aviez gagné d'argent avec la
presse est ce qu'avec les médias d'une
manière générale oui alors est ce que
c'est le cas avec le monde oui enfin pas
moi personnellement puisque l'argent que
j'aurais pu gagner potentiellement part
dans le fond dedans le fonds de dotation
d'accord pour pourquoi monsieur pigasse
nous a dit il ya quinze jours qui
n'avait pas gagné 1 euro avec le monde
parce qu'il n'a pas gagné 1 euro avec le
monde il évolue aussi dans le forez ce
que non parce qu'il a il a retouché
juste l'argent qu'il a émis dans bon
bilan des toujours contrôler
oui mais alors je comprends pas encore
quand vous dites que vous vous avez
gagné de l'argent vous étiez
actionnaires même quand j'ai gagné au
départ dans toutes les langues j'ai
gagné virtuellement de l'argent si
demain je j'avais dû céder ses
participations je lui passais des
mathieux de la cedh et ça lui a permis
de rembourser tout l'argent qu'il avait
mis dans le monde ce qui était
incroyablement le pour lui
financièrement puisqu'on avait pas d
tous les trois actionnaires du monde
n'avaient pas tous les mêmes niveaux de
fortune c'était incroyable mon lourd et
les solutions de mathieu quand il a eu
besoin d'argent pour s'occuper d'autres
activités se développer dans d'autres
médias a été de trouver des solutions
donc ils se voient rembourser de ses
investissements le l'investissement
total du monde ça a été je 330 millions
d'euros combien de 130 130 millions
d'euros 2 ou 3 c'est ça à trois avec
pierre bergé qui est parti à un moment
et mathieu qui a significativement
réduit son implication financière david
assouline
oui c'est c'est ma dernière question et
elle revient sur ce qui m'a marqué dans
cette audition je pense que je ne serai
pas le seul à être marqué par ce moment
là c'est quand vous avez dit en gros que
l'état avait
décidé poussé fait pression influait
pour que la fusion tf1 m6 puis se
réaliser
on vous a posé la question si à cette
fusion ils vont devoir céder des chaînes
est ce que vous êtes candidat allait
prendre vous avez refusé de répondre
en nous disant qu' elle ne se fera pas
alors je comprends pas très bien votre
certitude puisque vous avez voulu que ce
soit l'europe que les choses soient
tranchées
l'europe a dit non c'est à la france
donc maintenant
c'est l'art comme vous dites qu'elle est
sous influence c'est l'autorité de la
concurrence et vous dites aussi à peu
près la même chose qui doivent décider
donc en fait si on s'en tenait à votre
logique ça va être décidé c'est une
question de timing et puis il ya un
monsieur qui peut aller même au delà et
ne pas tenir compte de tous ces avis et
qu est le dernier mot c'est le ministre
de l'économie et des finances qu'on va
auditionner on lui posera d'ailleurs la
question
bon donc quelques est-ce que pouvez-vous
me dire sur quoi fondez vous
votre team is artitude ou alors ou alors
si c'est pas une certitude cet optimisme
en tous les cas très très fort sur le
fait pour vous optimisme parce que ça
serait du pessimisme pour monsieur oui
qu'on va auditionner juste derrière vous
en tout l'état qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire ça parce que ça n'est pas la
conséquence logique de vos analyses
précédentes
parce que je crois toujours que le bien
gagne c'est ça excusez moi de ma naïveté
c'est vous c'est quoi c'est un truc
d'entrepreneurs vous faites des trucs
tout le monde vous dit c'est pas
possible et puis ça marche c'était quoi
ma chance moi petit gamin à créteil dans
une cité s'ils voulaient d'être là
devant vous aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
logique alors je crois ou bien je crois
qu'en vous attention sont saines vous
avez raison il vous donnait quand vous
êtes fonctions sont pas bonnes mais ça
m'est arrivé dans la ville alors c'est
gagné pas donc j'ai cet optimisme
maintenant je vous rajoute un deuxième
élément
je crois que l'autorité de l'independent
autorités de la concurrence elle est
incroyablement des bombes je crois
qu'elle est diablement incroyablement
pardon excusez moi l'autorité la
concurrence est incroyablement
indépendante dépendant indépendante 1
excusez moi je m'en excuse dépendre de
vous avez dit
on à la mairie sa présidente pascale
vous voulez vous voulez poser des
questions indépendantes
mais pendant et si vous voulez ça reste
le dernier rempart dans cette histoire
là ça reste le dernier rempart et je
leur dis moi je crois qu'à la fin quand
il ya quelque chose qui est pas ça finit
toujours par perdre et ça finit toujours
par papa ce faire
ma conviction profonde ça concerne la
presse ça concerne tf1 m6 ça concerne la
production sait que la concurrence et la
diversité
c'est quand je peux vous dire ça
c'est la meilleure protection pour la
démocratie et vous avez des populistes
qui monte et on a besoin de cette
diversité on a on a besoin de pluralisme
sur tous les secteurs dont a parlé et ça
c'est incroyablement important et c'est
ça franchement que moi très modestement
j'attends de vous c'est ça c'est d'être
capable de
j'allais vous dire rétablir mais de
faire avancer ce sujet et d'aller plus
loin pour qu'on ait cette concurrence
qu'on ait ce pluralisme
qu'ils soient là et qui arrive dans ce
pays
le rapporteur ne m'en voudra pas mais
exceptionnellement j'ai posé une
dernière question parce que je trouve
qu'on n'est peut-être pas allé assez
loin sur la provence on sait que votre
concurrent sur cette opération fait une
offre de 80 millions d'euros quant à
votre été quatre fois inférieur qu'est
ce que ça signifie cette espèce de
surenchère sur la valeur de ce titre de
presse qu est-ce qu il ya pas un danger
plus générale autour de la valorisation
et plus précisément est-ce que vous
utiliserez votre droit de préemption
pour qui vous permettrait de racheter
les actions au prix de votre groupe
duran alors il ya deux éléments sur la
provence le donc c'est une société le
groupe bernard tapie en liquidation et
dispose de ses participations
contrôlante même si on allait droit
extrêmement important de la provence
dans le cadre de cette liquidation il
est légitimement deux expertises qui ont
été faites par le liquidateur ces deux
expertises ont dit
ça vaut 20 millions d'euros ces deux
experts nommés par le liquidateur
judiciaire il ya deux expertises qui dit
ça vaut 20 millions d'euros
visiblement peut se tromper ça vaut une
vingtaine de millions d'euros
localement vous avez un entrepreneur qui
lime énorme pour moi ça vaut 80 millions
d'euros alors est ce que ça vaut 20 ou
est ce que ça vaut 80 je pense qu'il ya
une motivation d'un repreneur locale
soutenue par tout tissu économique local
soutenu par tout le monde soutenu par
tout le monde localement je sais pas ce
qu'on fait après parce qu'on est soutenu
le calme quand on est soutenu par tout
le monde quand après on arrive dans les
médias ça pose quelques petits problèmes
mais soutenu par tout le monde pour dire
on va reprendre ce qu'on va reprendre
cette société là
les élus locaux la chambre de commerce
tout le monde et pour tout le monde
trouve ça fantastique
en toute franchise pour moi tout le
monde est d'accord je ne sais pas j'ai
un petit matin un petit truc qui sonne
quand il ya des gens qui sont prêts à
payer quatre fois le prix d'un truc j'ai
un petit truc qui sonne et je me dis
c'est pas normal ça donc si vous voulez
je me retrouve dans le sujet là en
disant est ce qu'il ya un moment donné
est ce qu'à un moment donné il n'y a pas
un problème et est-ce qu'il ya un moment
donné il faut pas
regarder ce qui se passe exactement
localement à côté de ça vous avez une
société avec des salariés
en procès à marseille en corse
il faut les rassurer il faut leur parler
on ne l'a pas fait aujourd'hui ce que
vous êtes dans le cadre d'un appel
d'offres on va le faire on va les
rassurer on va leur parler on a un
projet industriel un projet qui décide
qui a pour volonté de rendre la provence
rentable à une danseuse pas une danseuse
pas un truc dans lequel je mets de
l'argent et comme ça dans les dîners en
ville je sais fier je possède le média
du coin c'est exactement l'inversé ce
que l'on souhaite faire
et essayer de se dire dans ce monde là
est ce qu'on peut aider et si on peut
aider à ce que le pluralisme puisse
fonctionner localement on fera
votre droit de préemption crois que je
viens de dire quelque chose inverse qui
voudront peut-être d'accord
merci 1 dans le droit de préemption que
vous avez l'article 4 de la loi de 86
oui qui permet de la loi de 86 sur la
presse qui permet à tous
tout actionnaire d'ims d'une société de
presse d'agréer faut pas l'oublier tout
nouvel actionnaire donc si vous voulez
avant qu'on se fout de notre plan psion
on a quand même le droit d'être non nous
sommes déjà un premier jugement et vous
êtes en appel sur ce oui mais le
liquidateur lui-même a dit que le fin de
droit d'agrément il est dans la loi moi
je veux bien qu'un tribunal de commerce
tout seul dans un coin dit la loi ne
s'applique pas à marseille mais là on va
voir d'autres types de problèmes
et encore
merci mais je suis revenu pour réponses
à nos questions mais mes chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons dans une demi heure
pour le dissident une demi-heure pour
l'audition de martin week-end
une question
si si on va le faire par pardon il dit
non on ne l'a pas signalé alors monsieur
dit elle allez-y alesi à lisier merci
bonjour monsieur niel
des quelques entrepreneurs français qui
font votre fierté notre réputation
internationale avec un petit brin
d'insolence qui vous rend peut-être
immédiatement plus sympathique le choix
trois ans
dans des médias en a surpris plus d'un
même si comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez débuté très tôt avec
le recul j'aurais deux questions à vous
poser avec le recul qu'est-ce que vous
pensez avoir apporté à ce secteur et est
ce que vous êtes parvenu à ce que vous
souhaitiez première question par des
articles de presse récents tendance à
souligner votre évolution en matière de
télécoms notamment n'hésitant pas à
estimer vous n'êtes pas ces deux
trublions un consolidateur du marché
parce que votre vision de la
concentration économique a changé depuis
que vous avez débuté dans les télécoms
et les médias merci de vos réponses
merci madame la sénatrice
jeu
on va essayer dé
la volonté quand je suis arrivé dans ce
secteur des médias c'est de se dire on a
la possibilité d'avoir de la fois des
médias
rentable et indépendant et c'était ça le
pari et c'est un pari qui semblait
difficile puisque l'on promettait à la
presse une disparition certaine et
c'était réellement un sujet un véritable
sujet donc ce su si j'ai pu aider avec
d'autres encore une fois a amené à
permettre ou à aider la création de
nouveaux médias à permettre l'existence
et l'émergence de médias plus
indépendant et qui au bout soit rentable
modestement je serais ravi si si juste
une toute petite croix dans un coin
parce qu'encore une fois je je suis pas
le seul à on est plein je pense à penser
ça mais si j ai juste une petite croix
pour moi dans un coin je rêve j'en
serais ravi et est flatté
sur votre question je pense
malheureusement qu'on vieillit tous donc
le vieillissement parfois on le le le
celui qui se prenait pour un
révolutionnaire moins révolutionnaire et
c'est toujours très bien d'avoir des
articles de presse qui vous réveille et
qui vous dit ok mais c'est vrai
peut-être qu'à un moment on regarde plus
le monde de la même manière mais je
trouve ça remet un bon coup de pouce et
encore une fois c'est
je crois que c'est le côté sain de la
critique et quand vous voyez cet article
c'est dangereux ça vous fait référence à
un article du figaro je crois lundi
quand vous voyez ce type d'article
il a peut-être pas complètement tort et
donc vous ça vous redonne un petit coup
de blues et vous vous dites ok on va s'y
remettre et ont essayé de penser
différemment et de d'avoir des
initiatives différentes qui
correspondent
excusez-moi aux valeurs ou aux envies
que vous aviez en étant un grand
adolescent ou jeune adulte
pardon je m'excuse auprès de la
sénatrice renault garabédian j'avais pas
on m'avait pas signalé que vous vouliez
prendre la parole donc le désolé de vous
avoir omis